oceans cover over 70% of the Earth's
surface
they not only serve as the planets
largest habitat but also help to
regulate the global climate
[Music]
the ocean is a continuous body of salt
water that surrounds the continents it
is divided into four major regions the
Pacific Atlantic Indian and Arctic the
ocean contains traces of all chemical
elements found on earth but it tastes
salty because of sodium and chloride
ions in rainwater runoff and minerals
from geothermal vents on the sea floor
climate change is altering the ocean in
three major ways first the ocean is
getting warmer the greenhouse effect not
only warms the planet but also raises
the temperature of the world's oceans
over the past century the ocean surface
temperature rose at an average rate of
about point 13 degrees Fahrenheit per
decade and during the past 30 years sea
surface temperature has been
consistently higher than at any other
time on record this warmer water
vaporizes quickly fueling stronger and
more frequent storms higher temperatures
also threaten delicate ocean life like
coral reefs
and disrupt the food chain from krill to
penguins to seals
second since 1993 the seas have been
rising at a rate that's twice as fast as
the long-term trend
sea levels rise not only because water
expands when it heats up but also due to
melting glaciers and ice sheets rising
seas contribute to flooding on once dry
land in coastal regions a third
consequence of climate change is ocean
acidification seawater absorbs co2 from
the atmosphere which lowers its pH and
results in higher acid content this
reduces the concentration of calcium
carbonate which makes it difficult for
species like oysters clams and corals to
form shells or skeletons the only way to
stop the damage to our oceans is to
dramatically reduce greenhouse gas
emissions
but even if emissions stop tomorrow the
gas is currently in the atmosphere would
take decades to dissipate
[Music]